mr mark norman what's happening brother
hey
good to see you fatty it's been years
so much has happened the world's shut
down your
studio is like it's like my
ex-girlfriend she's gone black
yeah yeah man things have changed you
know
things are a little different now with
corrections
it were like kamala but we kicked biden
out you know we got really old man
so what how
how's new york man is it as bad as it
seems on tv or
it it's not that bad the bronx is rough
but uh
it's just everybody left and there's a
lot of hobos
and it's getting a little dicey but it's
still fun this comedy shows were on a
roof or in a parking lot you name it
i saw you doing comedy shows in uh parks
yeah yeah it's come to that
you're just doing it straight up what
gave you the idea doing parks just
because you were forced that's the only
place you can do it
yeah everybody's covered crazy so stand
up new york said hell we'll do it in a
park we'll get a microphone
and we'll hit our mailing list and now
we're in central park
i got birds [ __ ] on me i got sun
cancer i got a
mosquito biting me and there's kids
playing i'm talking about queefs
you know into a microphone under a tree
hey i heard you say
i heard you say uh you can actually hear
crickets like you know
people no it's crickets out there
because no seriously i can hear crickets
yeah complete it's bad man it's i call
it the methadone of comedy it's not the
real heroine but you just it gets you by
yeah we need the real thing but you can
go on the road some right like i've been
you know and i got i paid for it i was
the canary in the coal mine and i got
covered but
i've been on tour during this whole
pandemic yeah
same i've been doing like funny bones
and uh heliums
you know they're half full so i'm
finally selling out but
yeah it's i mean going into it because
it's magic it's like oh i didn't realize
what we had you know you're in a green
room
the crowd is hot it's great yeah you're
putting a lot of content out though i
think it's forcing
comics to kind of get more creative as
far as digital goes like i see putting
out a bunch more clips stuff like that
so
i think in one aspect that's good more
guys are getting creative and putting
content out so
people don't forget about them i guess
that's true
we're trying to stay relevant you gotta
get creative and i hope this uh
fluffs off a few you know hobbyists
you know if you weren't in it for the
love of it yeah hit the road
yeah if you're not doing because you
love it you know especially now you're
getting half pay on the road and stuff
like that those those other hacks aren't
out there you know
exactly exactly so hopefully because
comedy got real hot you know
youtube and netflix and all this [ __ ] so
everybody jumped on the bandwagon but
once they see it's tough uh i think
it'll be
i think it'll kick a lot of people out
hit the bricks i say
but you were smart because a few comics
did and few of them
failed but you're smart because you
released your special during the
pandemic right
yes good call good call yeah great time
to release content is during a pandemic
i mean people are stuck at home we're
quarantined
so i got some some pretty solid views on
that [ __ ]
that thing's over a mill yeah oh we're
3.6 there sloppy jalopy and counting
i feel like uh i was maybe uh
10 views of that i watched it and i also
posted it
thank you sir you've watched it more
times than my parents that's for sure
did you did you have it ready to go was
this planned
i shot it in january nobody would buy it
so i said [ __ ] it i'm shooting to myself
and uh thank god i did so then we just
edited it color corrected that thing and
put it out in may
how the [ __ ] did nobody buy it are you
pitching it yourself or having one of
those sleazy agents
kind of push it to netflix or comedy
central
i had a sleazy agent i had me i had
everything trying to push it but
you know i don't check any boxes i'm a
skinny white guy
it's a there's a lot of us you know i
know sarah cooper
so uh you know nobody wanted it so what
what can you do
they don't even watch it they don't
watch it they just go ah we don't like
the look
he looks like a douche [ __ ] him and i'm
kind of glad i put it on my own now it's
a blessing in disguise because
i get all the money i can chop it up i
own it yes
yeah i think you know schultz is doing
the same thing too although now he might
you know be going with a major
distributor but i think
it's strange because you're such a beast
at the art of stand up that they
wouldn't look at it and give you a
platform because is it
frustrating for you because you know
every comic is gonna say you know you
talk about
guys who are great at the craft right
now no one says mark norman's not
up there you know top 10 right now so
you talk to anyone you know so is it
frustrating for you you know you're
[ __ ] you're good at comedy man it has
to be frustrating oh
hey thanks i can't take a compliment but
uh
yeah it's frustrating it was more
hurtful like hey you worked so hard at
something
and you you [ __ ] slave over this
thing
no offense and it just
you know it just sucks
because
by the way it's so great having a black
people in the room because in new york
everybody's
so tense with everything so it's it's
nice black people laugh
and then these these stiff honkies out
there go oh what are you doing
but yeah yeah it's uh it's a pain in the
ass it's a bummer you know what can you
do it
because funny now is 13th on the list of
what people want in
in the industry of comedy you know and
and the business side they don't give a
funny funny's out i mean look at all the
specials
these days they're pretty rough so um
you know i don't know i don't fit them
all but [ __ ] it i'm on youtube and
youtube seems to be
youtube's now feel like what podcasts
were eight years ago
everybody's like there's no money in
that [ __ ] that and now look at podcasts
yeah and i think more comics can realize
that they have the power and
you actually get more views unless
you're like a seinfeld or chris rock or
you know chappelle if you're if you're
not those guys you're going to get more
views put on youtube and owning all them
and
posting clips and promoting it there
because everybody can get youtube
exactly exactly yeah and i think the
good sticks out a little bit
and the people talking i mean look at
reddit red is just a big
sewing circle full of dweebs and incels
and they get together and they start
clamoring and then boom you got a hit
agree man no i think you were smart
brother uh
how's your how's everything have you
seen have you seen your reddit it's
[ __ ] terrifying
no these people are nuts i stay off of
it man i stay off it i just
read it and now i stay off and hopefully
do you read them you read all that [ __ ]
i have it boy i had to i had to turn my
lights off close the blinds and get in
the fetal position for three weeks so
it's so painful
yeah yeah i don't know man i yeah i
don't look for validation from uh
guys on reddit fortunately smart move
how's how's things going with the with
the lady friend out there during
quarantine
pretty good pretty good you know a lot
of movies
we're cooking it's it's like a lifetime
movie over here you know where we
she's got a little icing on her nose and
i i i rape her you know it's fun
because for a lot of couples this this
pandemic this quarantine has
caused him to break up you know it's
been rough to hang out through
no this was good where we we hang we
we like a little down time it's not so
bad so we're having a good go at it
and uh also with comedy i was on the
road i was out every night so
i know we didn't even know each other
until the pandemic yeah you're forced to
get to know each other
do you miss the hang like i'm sure
you're at the cellar and stuff missing
the boys
or do you still see people out there ah
i miss everybody but
we're getting there a little like the
cellar still open they have dinner
so like i had lunch with sam morillo the
other day i see joe list with the
podcast
uh you know podcasting is really keeping
me with seeing all my friends ironically
thank god for those but we have free
time so we sit in the park we had a
cigar with ari two days ago i mean
we're getting out there you gotta see
the pals and and stay
sane is uh are a lot of your buddies in
new york especially the comics are they
are they leaving new york cause new york
is a [ __ ] show like is in la so
all my friends have left so that's why
you just see me now
oh yeah yeah what are you what are you
going to do i mean
my friends are still here uh no one's
stuck in our lease
no one's living in new york no nobody's
leaving in new york no the main comics
or anything
not really not really like all the big
ones are still here you know you're a
tell
your colin quinn seinfeld they're all
staying
they all have more money than me but i
don't know new york you kind of
get that apartment if they're so hard to
find and you you get
you put your roots in this place like
joey diaz is back now
tim hilton comes back every now and then
schultz was born here
yeah you know like we're staying i don't
know i'm proud of l.a
l.a seems worse with the shutdown uh
i don't know l.a a lot of a lot of
frauds you know like as soon as things
got rough everybody dipped out it's like
what
i thought what happened oh everyone's
gonna leave what the [ __ ]
i know i know well you got you got chris
sure and bill burr i guess are staying
but
yeah even like theo and segora here is
leaving
and uh you know diaz
yeah it's tough rogan rogan that's tough
man
yeah it's a bit of a bummer but i think
once things opened up
those guys would be in and out of la so
they might have left but they'll be in
and out hopefully
you know it's just about yeah it's just
a bummer because like
even at the store they were trying to
put on shows outside and they had like a
bar and they had outside
shows and the city shut them down that's
where we're at
ah that's what i hear i mean the taxes
the shutdown it feels like it's getting
nutty the hobos
i mean yeah you guys are what's the
upside after a while if you can't go to
the beach you can't go to the nice
restaurants
the taxes are you know [ __ ] on your
face you're kind of screwed
yeah but taxes are jizz in your face in
new york as well my man
that's true but we got the comedy clubs
are opening up the stand is opening now
the seller
so we're paying for it sure but at least
we got some amenities coming in
yeah you right i'll give you that you're
right you any predictions on the
election next week
i will say this i don't know anything
about politics i've never voted in my
life
uh i know that's uh you can't say that
[ __ ] now but i'm clueless i don't watch
the news really
but i say this i travel the country and
all i see is trump
posters and flags that's what i think
what keep going that's what i keep
saying like if i think if you're in la
in new york you're like oh biden's
winning for sure
yeah as soon as i get out i'm like oh
[ __ ] i think trump's gonna win
i know exactly so it's a toss-up because
like all these people are voting early
it's a record amount of votes have come
in for biden
already so but that's what we said about
hillary so
what the hell do i know but i just hope
trump loses so we can stop talking about
trump i got trump fatigue
everybody's got their 20 minutes on
trump and it's hacky now and
every news story but here's the question
there shaby
[Laughter]
every comedy show is trump-based colbert
seth myers snl uh samantha b
it's all trump trump trump jokes so then
what happens
if he loses are those shows gonna go
under i i don't know they're screwed
that's the only material they have all
their riders are just anti-trump it's
the only thing they have
what happens to cnn what the hell are
they giving yeah
yeah he's a ratings booster so
who knows who knows i just i hate that
we're so political now we're so divided
it's it's all very strange
agree brother well hopefully uh after
election i do think things are going to
open up in new york you're already
headed in the right direction
because i was going to do shows at the
uh forgot what theater i was at out
there do you remember what theater
gramercy i was at the gram scene you
were gonna we were gonna do shows
together
so yeah hopefully next year i'll i'm
gonna rebook
new york and we'll be able to do shows
together man that'd be nice it'd be nice
to see
it i mean just to have a show planned in
the books feels good now because the
calendar is so empty everybody keeps
canceling which you know i get it but
boy i gotta tell you this pandemic has
made me grateful for comedy i i
kind of took it for granted like ah
going to jfk again here we go
funny bone merchandise you know closer
waitress you know but uh now i love it i
get to a green room i'm like oh give me
those wings
give me a cocktail let's go bust it out
and do some jokes
and the hotel room and all that but yeah
i didn't know what i had
i agree man well when i get to new york
it's gonna be thick crust and mark
norman that's the plan brother
here here let's do it baby all right
brother
well we we miss you man and uh
appreciate you coming on man even though
it's zoom
it's better than nothing man yes yes
it's good to see it's it's
it's not the real thing but it's it's
phone sex
you know i still i still orgasmed
wait am i done already that was what
what am i quibby it's over
it's quick
geez that was four minutes but all right
i'll see you buddy
here come here do you have any shows
coming up
are you on the road again i am i am i
mean i'm in
atlantic city this weekend at ac comedy
club next weekend i'm at
cleveland hilarity's great club great i
got a ton of shows in the books
you know buffalo new orleans you name it
so uh
we on buffalo helium yeah helium
that's a great club oh yeah
so yeah come on out folks say hello
i'll hug give a hug dude
give a hug are you wearing masks are you
wearing are you wearing a master in the
meet and greets
i am but uh i've already had it so i
kind of feel invincible
me too i love it yeah so that's nice
how was that was it rough for you
yeah it was about three days of hell but
it just came and went
yep yep yep yeah mine wasn't too bad but
for
everyone's different i guess i think so
i think if you're fat
or uh gay you're [ __ ] but uh
no i'm kidding i'm kidding but yeah hey
i'll see you on the road baby
kanye 2020.
[Laughter]
all right brother we got your special up
now so you guys can go watch it now it's
uh out to lunch it's on youtube
that's mark norman we love you man we
miss you and i'll see you soon in person
same here baby praise allah
he's my favorite when i get off stage at
the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this from a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son